[Music]
seeing a nearly 50 decrease in
population over the past decade this is
the radiated tortoise
endemic to the dry southern forests of
madagascar the radiated tortoise has an
amazingly long lifespan the oldest
tortoise on record reached an estimated
188 years old
their shell is domed and highly
intricate with bright yellow star
patterns radiating outwards on each
plate
the shells have both blood vessels and
nerves meaning that it can feel when
it's being touched
the sharp decline in the tortoises
population is mostly due to hunting and
the black market pet trade in madagascar
their meat is considered a delicacy and
illegal poaching has decimated wild
populations
additionally their distinctive markings
on their shells have made them desirable
as pets
it's estimated that a staggering quarter
of a million radiated tortoises are
harvested each year
conservationists estimate these animals
could go extinct in less than 20 years
this is the radiated tortoise
[Music]
you